good morning millenials sorry we're a
little bit late I've been constipated
since Tuesday Margo gave me a coffee
this morning and it didn't help it just
made me ill so sorry that we're delayed
but look out the bowels don't know that
it's 10:30 you know the bowels have
really not been on our side this weekend
no no we almost missed our flight
hello welcome to the morning toast today
it's Monday October 8th and it's a
snitch on the toast situation right and
we've never done a state on the toast
together yeah
snitch on the child we've never had a
situation with switching and ones right
because I'm a deadbeat co-host and
markers usually filling in for me but
think Jackie's the deadbeat co-host
today because I get to have snitch on
the toast today and joey camasta
tomorrow there was a little bit of
confusion we were supposed to have
Lauren Burnham today but she had a
conflict so she won't be here but that's
fine because we have so much catching up
today and they're like I'm a little too
tired I could've been that I know and
when I woke up I was like slightly
relieved because like I would've had to
look so pretty for Lauren right and I
could just look ugly for you like I do
every day of course no this is actually
a step up I'm kidding I'm getting it up
on my phone okay no well you Jackie
usually chooses the stories and then
like five minutes before we're supposed
to go I realize that like I had to do
that today and I feel like I did a good
job I think these are Jackie level level
story is well rounded of course but
Before we jump right in let's talk about
our our wild weekend own life on the
road
it was truly it was the road no totally
usually I'll do like one show and two
shows in one city and then come on like
the max I'm gone is like two and a half
days maybe three right but we were gone
literally a week Wednesday since
Wednesday with 12 hours here oh my god
it was so treacherous oh my god I
learned a lot I don't think I'll ever do
that again
Oh me neither I mean I have no choice
but like I don't think I'll ever book
myself like that all right
I'm my best like in my show when I'm
like well rested right and we did a good
job with like really making sleep and
rest a priority I would be so crazy he's
like we were talking about how we I
can't really nap and like all this stuff
but for some reason like when we wanted
to go to sleep at any hour we did any
like plane ride like
it was great and it was just so
treacherous because we went to
Huntsville as our final stop and there
are no big kept saying Huntsville is
like an International Airport because
there's no direct flights there so we to
fly to Atlanta and then to Huntsville
which for a one stop flight it was the
least treacherous it could be but it's
still no nonstop I've never done a one
stop like that was my first time and
like yeah it was bad but like I'll ever
do it like by choice I'll ever I have to
but it wasn't terrible it wasn't it I
think suppose we got good airports yeah
like we had to chill in Albany
I mean Atlanta and we were flying Delta
and Atlanta is like their headquarters
and we got massages like it was the
nicest Airport and there was a cascais
hub in every single terminal and like
for some reason we just got so fortunate
that they were net if stargate every
time and we don't have that kind of
blood we're always at the gate furthest
away right because when we started this
trip in albany we flew out of JFK and we
were ain't gate b-52 and just so you
know when you start walking the gates
it starts with 25 and b-52 is like
literally I would say over a mile down
over down two escalators and we caught a
golf cart and even the golf cart we
still had to walk because it couldn't be
beat and so far it was just like it was
so physically taxing which is why I
think I'm sick yeah and like being on
planes that much isn't good but honestly
like I definitely lost five pounds
because we didn't like we didn't stop no
I know but then what I didn't lose five
pounds like when we ate we didn't eat
great but we ate so infrequently because
we had no time to eat that like if
you're eating so little it doesn't even
matter what you're eating
weenie vineet badly yeah because we
never ate yeah except for like and
yesterday was a bad day for me but
that's not all it was [ __ ] lettuce
and cheese you ever gross comedy clubs
yeah and like we didn't do it it was but
we ended up in Alabama which like I made
the whole thing guy it made the whole
trip worth it totally and also like had
it been Friday night and Albany was
Saturday like we wouldn't have had as
good of a time because that we would
have had to prepare for another show the
next day and we just like would have
been like oh just go to sleep
yeah but but Alabama is my favorite
place now ok I thinking about going back
this weekend to Birmingham oh my god you
should also book a show in Birmingham
I'm working on it but also like a bunch
of my friends from LA are gonna be there
for the weekend and I'm gonna be in
Atlanta on Friday tickets available
Carla job comment believe there's like
only a hundred left and they're like I'm
really like a 30-minute flight away
right now I just want to be home I know
I do I want to miss out on the roll tide
vibes
where are dimes are high okay so if you
go to Alabama there's two teams roll
tide and then another one that's like
less cool but everyone just says roll
tide and like people were commenting on
my Instagram RT R and I'm like [ __ ] this
other RI was anybody thinking Rent the
Runway and I was like why support a
grunt the runway and then I realize
because my shirt said world tied its
roll tide roll okay fine fine I was
actually thinking that to ort our yeah
but I don't watch the [ __ ] when I don't
have the comments here on my phone I
feel like no one's watching the show do
you know they are I have it up would you
already mean yes also we kept saying
roll tide but I don't know the name of
the team do you I'll do what rollers
cats I don't know Alabama Crimson Tide
that's what I comes from and then it's
the other Clemson War Eagles Clemson
Eagles weren't I don't know no not
Clemson Auburn Auburn Auburn whatever
whatever I got cold shirts ever lie
about it
real tied so I just feel like a
different woman we have had no time to
relax so after this I know you really
want to hang out but I have a full full
but I mean I'm like booked back-to-back
in appointments I thought we had an
appointment
to do nothing together yeah like we both
wanted to see a star is born but I just
can't get myself out of bed to see ya
know like I woke up this morning I was
like wow I can't believe I have to do
this that I need to see a star was born
me too the reviews are in and even
Taylor Kinney did you hear what he said
no I said who's like she's working so
hard I'm so proud of her and yeah I've
always hit them I love him I'm holding
out hope I'm not because she isn't she
like engaged to someone else you think
it sure agent from CIA and to be honest
he's like not that cute he's no Taylor
Kinney Taylor Kinney still [ __ ] he's
so hot and he has a consistent paycheck
which I love yeah he's cashing those NBC
Trump checks yeah
and Chicago Fire is actually really good
I really like it kiss fire yeah it's
fire Kelly severide
does this feel weird cuz like we just
talk about this normally and it's weird
to like to do it on camera
writing up straight and like with makeup
on but this is really like how we talk I
feel we were talking to you H I think
that we're acting because we're not
because we're not right okay well we're
here all week
thank God Friday we head to Atlanta I'm
not sure what time my flight and so we
might miss Friday on the toast we are
missing we are the toast it's so Kylie
retractable co-host or like we'll just
need a break Jack is in Dallas would
Zack obviously
and I'm gonna land on Friday it's my
biggest venue yet it's actually the same
size it's the Wilbur theater so I've
been putting all this pressure on my
Boston shows like Wilbur theater well
we're theater like Atlanta yeah so I'm
like really nervous now you'll be so
fine we're gonna be great
great my first actually my second
theater you just say the theater wait oh
yeah no I don't think my first hitter
was in Denver oh can we talk about
Albany no yeah oh my god we okay so we
went to Buffalo and it's honestly just
like it was very Buffalo
it was my doubt the inspector and I
really was upset cause it was no Buffalo
Wild Wings and I thought that's where it
started so we weren't ready to start on
a great foot right I'm gonna just
expected the same from all but neighbor
like oh this is another city in New York
that's not Manhattan right and it was
premium as [ __ ] totally just give a
shout out I wanted to tell everyone's
shout from the rooftops about my hotel
but I didn't want people to like come to
kill me the Renaissance is the best
hotel I've ever say that not in ever
it's in Albany in my life it might as
well have been the Four Seasons I think
it is for Albany it was so gorgeous they
had Netflix and Hulu lives oh my god we
ordered room service twice for like the
three hours and he's preparing quickly I
think we're the only people really
staying in the hotel let's see another
person it was just so [ __ ] premium
and when we are on the road like we are
our budget is limited for hotels so like
more often than not depending if it's
like a mark like a good market your
hotel options are very limited we've
seen some [ __ ] yeah we've seen some [ __ ]
but if it's like not a top-20 market
whatever they call it the hotels are so
much cheaper and we can get more for our
money
so Albany the Renaissance was so [ __ ]
late so nice and then in Alabama we
stayed in a hotel me were very
trepidatious cuz we saw it on the
itinerary more like I've never heard of
that it was called the Ella man and it
was [ __ ] premium as hell also yes it
was great but more at a pool more often
than not it's like a Hampton Inn
Doubletree situation which depending on
where you are isn't terrible I've grown
a lot of respect for him didn't meet you
know like the Holiday Inn that we stayed
at in new years he was the nicest hotel
I've ever stayed at because they also
gave us like the Presidential Suite
right but then like the the Kimpton
which you think is like a nice oh my god
in DC was truly I think that's what
really got my sickness start started
because it was so moldy anger there was
totally horrible bacteria in the moldy
Murphy air Margeaux it was like walking
around the room in the carpet and every
time she stepped on the carpet it
sounded like a wet mop being
like a squeegee it was disgusting he's
disgusting oh my God my socks from that
day that was a tough trip so like I'm
just learning a lot about hotels
I'm wonder what about travel and I find
that like boutique hotels it like
millenials love like those are the worst
they're more expensive and they're so
[ __ ] expensive and they're so small
but then like the the chains that people
like a rag on like Holiday Inn love it
love it I love a [ __ ] chain okay
anything else run every cup before me
Devon um what about like a night out and
Alabama we talked about it the Alabama
the Huntsville toasters were so [ __ ]
premium so [ __ ] premium like that
boner concert the concert the concert
was great just like good vibes like to
be like in a country town and we went to
Lauren Alaina Dustin Lynch Cole Swindell
concert and it was in a big arena and me
and my girl obviously like snuck our way
backstage and like nobody literally did
but nobody stopped up nobody just out
there in New York
everyone's like let me see your pass and
we just like walk you have to pretend
like you know where you're coming then
no one questions you and nobody Jenna me
made our way back to Cole Swindell
dressing room and he had a bar set up
and we took beer from him it was great
he's like no one's talked to us no one
stopped us it was crazy and like we had
some wristbands but not the ones but
like definitely not the ones we needed
but nobody cared nobody I mean he spent
we watched a whole concert from
backstage Cole Swindell was so premium
so hot I didn't notice how many Bing or
see as me neither and he waved to us ya
know there was there was a point where
it was just us and him because we were
the only people at that backstage part
and he was just singing us and we like
me incarnated in other words cause we'd
another song we were like you gotta
pretend yeah it was very premium and
then by the constant time MacArthur was
over we were like pretty drunk and I was
like do we want to go out we have a
flight and like we're so treacherous but
I'm like we've earned it you're only in
Alabama once that's maybe twice if I go
this weekend so we I do not regret going
to whiskey bottom oh my god the toasters
I'm like where the hell is everyone and
you know every time I go to a city
there's like a lot of pressure for me to
go out but tour life is so treacherous
that like if I go out it can ruin my
next show yeah also especially if we
have a show the next day like it's just
not gonna happen right and I feel bad
because I think like there's like this
expectation so I try and do it but like
for the most part I've decided that I'm
not gonna do it because I just can't
right it's just too much for me like
people don't know be like we get to the
venue and do sound check out like three
o'clock know we're there from like
literally from like for to like midnight
if I had I'd show so it's like what's
fairly treacherous
and we're always upset cuz we want to go
to dinner afterwards but it's midnight
and we just got to go home we always
make these big plans like we're on our
way and we only had one show in
Huntsville and it sold out I [ __ ]
love everyone who came and it was like
Alabama like we gotta go so he went to
this place called whiskey bottom and it
was just [ __ ] lit oh my god I had a
mechanical bull that we rode country
music and you know what it is it's like
it was a busy bar and if you like any
bar in New York that's busy it's like
sardines you can't breathe and like
literally someone could like rope you
when you wouldn't know who it was right
but it was a busy bar in Alabama and it
was huge and like it felt poppin but
like you had space to dance there was
and it was a really big space like and
also you could get to the bar like just
like you can easily and they had like a
coyote ugly thing like if you got on the
bar they gave you free drinks and like I
wanted to do it but I needed a drink
before and then I forgot to do it right
yeah I just realized I forgot about that
also the huntsville toasters the alabama
toasters were so late so many people
drove in i love doing shows on like
Friday and Saturday nights because that
means people like have time to drive in
so people came in from Nashville from a
lot of our constancy Lee yeah mostly
from Arkansas I don't know the map so I
don't know if that's close maybe they
have to look up the map to see where
Alabama was because I literally had no
idea it's between it's right next to
Georgia yeah it's on the left of Georgia
if you're looking at the map I'm excited
to go to Atlanta ya know I've only been
once and it was at the University of
Atlanta which you think is in Atlanta uh
no sorry University of Georgia and it's
like an hour outside Atlanta and I was
only there for a day and it was
extremely treacherous so I'm excited to
go back on my own terms
right and I'm excited to do the Atlanta
show tickets available at galco.com
the VIP is sold out and I think people
are like waiting for me to release more
but I can't cuz that's the capacity so
just buy your tickets before they're
gone are you done I think I'm done with
so anything else want to address no okay
thanks very much covered it well without
further ado it is now time that we
introduced you but that's the chyann
best five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast first one is
something so obvious that happened
yesterday when Margo we were on the
plane that happened to Margot DM did to
me like right before we took off and it
was so crazy
oh yeah Charles Milton and by the way I
have the story from me news and I just
look I have to make fun of the way that
this is written but also deliver the
news Charles Melton kisses Camilla
Mendez in new photo amid romance of
rumors
there's no timers there anymore this is
sort of literally confirmed
so it's like this article whoever wrote
it like just there's mommy maybe like a
2.2 percent chance that it's not true
and they did not want to be held
responsible ready things are heating up
in Riverdale
Camilla Mendes and Charles Melton have
been oh my god they'd the same initials
I know I was thinking that she wouldn't
if they get married she does that's a
chain he thought about that Camilla
Mendes in Charles Melton have been
sparking romance of rumours as of late
and Mendes may or may not have just
confirmed that what Oliver Annika lodges
fans have been hoping for no no no she
did confirm they kissed and she said
he's mine right Mendes posted an
Instagram photo of the two of them
locked in an embrace as he kisses over
her eye she captioned the photo mine
okay I mean if you're a true toaster and
a longtime toaster you've known this for
a while because they might they're
having dinner I catch making out
literally months ago and the toasters
like took a picture of it and we knew it
but this is my theory okay I have a
theory also but I've been feeling it's
the same thing so I'll let you tell it
so we knew it and I feel like they were
heating up they were starting to date
and I think they were about to announce
it and then some of Charles mountain
Melton's old tweets that were extremely
controversial came out he was just
making like really not in tune jokes
about fat girls and people were very
upset and I think that she held off on
announcing it and I actually think that
relationship she had with her boyfriend
mr. Houston from high school was like
completely fabricated and because there
are rumors and pictures of them making
out a catch that started in the toasters
to avoid any sort of confusion she likes
stated that she was dating this guy I
never saw a picture of them I saw a
picture of them but only he posted them
and she misses yes she never never saw
anything that would make me believe and
I follow her an instrument I'm a big fan
of hers and if it wasn't for that
picture on e news of her saying of them
saying that she's dating Victor Houston
I would have never known I knew just
because like I'm a psycho and I see
everything has passed I think she's cool
with people knowing that she's dating
but that whole storyline like of them
breaking up of them getting backs of
them being together all that stuff was
like so basic I don't even think they
kissed
yeah no no like they definitely don't
even know each other know that I think
they did go to high school together and
I think it was like friends helping
friends like she was making him like
nobody wants to be an actor and like
this was she was helping his star I role
of a lifetime right well now you said
something interesting yesterday that you
think that you
really hoping that like this doesn't
change the narrative on Riverdale we're
like Reggie's dating Veronica because
that would make no sense because like
the thing is is that the Riverdale like
fan base it's very like in tune with the
whole thing and like writer Ross really
does kind of listen to them in the sense
like so he was never break up bug head
because like he knows that people will
literally [ __ ] lose their minds yeah
so I don't but like now it's just very
weird because we all know so much about
what's going on behind the scenes that
it's like what about Archie now like it
just kind of it's really weird that
there's these like four couples and like
he's very out of it but thank now it's
hard to believe in barchi like I just
it's hard to do it's hard to separate
reality from from the [ __ ] right but I'm
pretty sure that she does get a new love
interest um Veronica's she said that at
one of the Comic Cons no yeah so like as
long as it's not Reggie cuz then it's
just like that's a joke but why one can
yg so what you just start dating your
co-star and then you're dating in the
show like the like why in the show
wouldn't that make sense don't say no is
what makes sense oh I'm saying it's just
it's a little too coincidental okay now
I want to ask your opinion because I
always feel like there is some unspoken
tension between Camilla Mendes and Lilly
Reinhardt like and they are best friends
and I'm not trying to pit women against
one another only the world that we live
in is like constantly comparing the two
and you just noticed so I'm like a huge
Lilly Sam and I feel like most people
are Camilla Stanley I don't know why but
I like that why do you have to only do
one hello you know fine
true but I'm saying like from what I
hear like people just like love Camilla
and I'm like wait what like I totally
thought Lily was like uh just my
favorite the favorite but so I'm a
psycho and I like see I like to see how
many followers each of them have just
because from the show they've all gotten
so many followers like it's crazy
million yeah and so all this time
Camilla always always had more me
probably by like the point two of a
million which is well like two hundred
thousand you did a lot but she turns out
premium content on the tailing that she
does Lilly post like one less frequently
yeah but I just recently realized that
Lilly has officially surpassed Camilla
and like Camilla hasn't been catching up
right but see all the difference of just
the point to but it's just interesting
to see that now Lily's ahead well and
also the Met Gala of it all
oh my god I mean I mean the fact that
Lilly Reinhardt and Cole were invited
it's just so epic because like it's a
teenybopper show and like good on Vogue
for being in tune with what's necessary
for once and go down
hmm actually but it is kind of weird
that like there are these two stars like
they both catapulted to fame from the
show and only one of them was invited
obviously because she's a part of this
like couple and I don't think she
would've been invited on her own right
but this begs the question it's like
they're trying to compete with : Lilly
well I don't really think it's a
competition
only because : Lilly don't really post
like they sometimes do and they have
those like cryptic things that like
whatever blurred photos Lilly has never
posted a picture with Cole and written
mine and she never will like refused to
address the fact that they're dating
even though like they are but I'll
confirm it it's like it's kind of
infuriating and we know that they are
and they're not - it's not that they're
denying it or they're just they refuse
to like give in to the pressure of like
the press which I kind of respect I do
too but I once read a interview with
Cole and he was like once I do it once
it's expected of me always so I'm just
never gonna do it right and that's what
even Jackie used to say it's like it's
weird that certain people feel the need
to like give life updates via statement
- like the press which like it's just
the world that we live in and like I
hope one day to get to that level but
like when you're born into it it's like
why do I have to tell everyone my
business also I feel like it's making
their relationship so much better and
like they're so legit and like normal
and whatever but they lately have been
like giving away more tidbits like just
likes Lilly response to clap backs on
Twitter being I know he does this like
they are together but they just won't
like put it everywhere and I feel like
Camilla and Charles will which is
totally finding them here for it and
they want to see it but I think that
gets the Instagram numbers up and I
think it's two totally different couples
so you can't even really compare them
all so I call is like kind of a legend
right now he's my new celebrity yeah but
and he's now successfully made the
transition from child actor to adult
actor like more seamlessly they have the
ideal transition I think how does that
say like who in the hell is their agent
because even Dylan he has this new
gorgeous girlfriend Barbara - girlfriend
identical twin identical twin it's to be
raising when they both have their hair
in ponytails they're twins and it's like
he's now like it I'm sure like he's
coming up with her at all this and like
he's doing movies and I'm sure I know a
little yeah so it's like and not like
they're so normal
they have this huge Disney career had
the foresight to be like okay let's take
a break went to college for four years
and graduated they're both like really
smarts who's made they went to college
with me yes
and I used to see them around all the
time NYU and I did give Cole Sprouse my
number one time you did yes I didn't
know that I wanted to take him on a date
to our goatee wait why the library yes
shoot I shot my shot wait can you tell
us sorry I don't know this at all
no you people just used to see them
everywhere and Cole was like the lessor
look good-looking one he really hadn't
come into himself yet puberty wise and
Dylan was so hot and had this girlfriend
he was like a photographer and they were
together forever I think her name was
Dina or Gina yeah she actually made in
her story so they were just like look
and they it's not like they were about
they'd ormd nobody at NYU even dorms
like they dreamed all through a village
of ladies they were one of them I can't
remember was the president of our dorm
the one that I lived in and that was
like the worst one and he was the
president of it so crabby I think he
might have been doing um Cole was an
archaeology major or like something with
map making maps another one with the
digging you know when your algae yeah
and then he needed his fossil brush and
I don't remember what Dylan was I think
it was something digital like video like
something and they were really like
local celebrities and it was like you
would see them everywhere they were real
students like Emma Watson is a student
Karlie Kloss is a student of nya that's
Sophia right yeah once and that you
never see them like dylan and Cole went
to NYU like they ate in the cafeteria
like they were they stood a dorm they
were hardcore students and they were
like local celebs and it was really cool
and in the library ones like we saw him
in like we just like it was so special
to see them and I just like brought my
never done I gave to him did he like say
he said thanks and he never texted me oh
man whatever he's cause it's so funny
yeah wait but you know so crazy said
Camila 1:10 my you to like with at your
time she did yes and she said one said
she like saw Cole on campus and like it
was like well it's so funny to watch
interviews from Riverdale like season
one press there because this was before
they all really knew each other and they
were all saying how like when they found
out Cole was gonna be on the cast they
were like freaking out cuz like for
awesome Billy is like Leonardo DiCaprio
like Suite Life of Zack & Cody like I've
seen every episode me too and on tech
that was the greatest thing they ever
did to make another show off ya know
they were very in tune and they
obviously have good parents who like
they made a ton of money yeah and then
they they chilled and I feel like if
they never got back into show business
they wouldn't have cared right but he
randomly took this role not knowing that
it was gonna literally change his life
and really bring up Dylan to write and
now they're just both like so real
and I'm so here for it and I feel like
they don't do drugs and I like that me
too I feel like they have good parents
they totally have good parents and also
like big Big Daddy yeah like they just
like have done everything all right they
were in friends I know I know I know I
know but no I'm very happy for them very
happy for like I just feel like everyone
is really like just like I feel like the
Riverdale cast hopefully is very just
like normal
yeah well we're gonna find ones that
like they're not but you know what I
just don't believe it but it's on the
blind it's like what happens is like
this is stereotypical like what happens
on a TV show of young kids who get
famous really fast they become like
quick friends and like everything and
like their life is amazing and everyone
loves them and they all hang out
together and makes the show even better
like they're in the offline really
brings the show it elevates the show
even more because people become more
invested in them but what happens is
like in Hollywood that can only happen
for so long before they all start hating
each other and fighting it's like Gossip
Girl right so and like an unknown she
went oh do you know AnnaLynne McCord was
on this show she said like at first it
was amazing and then we all like didn't
know what we had and we were insane and
we were monsters you know it's so weird
though that I was thinking about it's
like I feel like on all the shows that
we used to watch like hurry up like I'm
gossamer or like there were all these
couples and whatever like people would
like hook up and stuff like you never
really they actually knew about it but
because now their social media Instagram
like people are like coming out as
couples but then it's like you're gonna
break up and then it's gonna be a whole
thing but we never really knew about it
right like how did we know even Lea
Michele and Cory Monteith word together
because like we read it in People
magazine and and like they were so
together they'd like talk about it on
Ellen yeah but like that's that they
don't do that now I'm like season one
but they started dating probably like
season five in real life and that was
like more in the digital age like season
1 when nobody knows Lea Michele was like
hooking up and dating with Matthew
Barnett to Mars and who plays mr.
Schuester
yeah um like nobody knew that you're
right it's so weird it's so weird also
how did we know how did we know that
Blake Lively Penn Badgley were acting
weird eating right now because
papa-paparazzi that's really how we
found out stuff interesting and like
tabloids and we used to like really like
rely on tabloids and airports like to be
our source of it like yes we used to
like of knowledge described to magazine
yeah but now I go to an airport and like
I see what they write on the cover and
it's like it's like it's intentionally
stupid like in Ted only a [ __ ] would
believe what
right but we used to use that as our
number-one source of information so like
maybe we changed or maybe everything we
thought is not true hmm it's true no is
no no maybe everything we read that we
thought was true wasn't sure maybe
they've been lying this whole time and
we just bought it because there was no
other means of you know maybe right
right right that yeah and that's why
people that was like a growing so I
wasn't listening that's a good point
there was then now there's like a real
hatred for tabloids because celebrities
have outlets to like really give their
own news right but before they had to
rely on like People magazine to get
their stuff out there right so true
right but I think I think people is is
it a tabloid to people out of all them
people is the most reputable but still
all those articles are [ __ ] like I
used to love Star Magazine course it was
so true and now it's like oh my god now
it's really great for the photos like on
an airplane in the crossword puzzle like
this jars no just like us right love
that but not for information really just
for like enjoyment and like aesthetic
pleasure right well like I'm obviously
I'm very happy for Camilla and Charles
I'm happy that they came out but we all
knew yeah and it was it's just but I
know what she's a rising star she has to
protect her her image and you know I
respect it and I'm just I'm happy to see
I feel like she's gonna be churning out
so many like all that stuff and like we
never get that from the Riverdale cast
I'm excited to see it all just we get it
a lot for madelung patch and her
boyfriend but I don't like him I don't
like him and honestly like I like Cheryl
more than I like Madeline does that make
sense yes and I feel like
what's-his-name
Travis Travis like she's too Chiru Bukh
and precious and like her skin is so
soft to be dating someone who like look
so rough like he's like rough and she
just she needs like a like I don't know
I don't know softer oh yeah I totally
feel that but like there she's like
obsessed with him yeah I know like I
think she likes him more than he likes
her yeah I always like to evaluate
celebrity couples I mean like who likes
you more than the other look like you in
the Lilly home in every relationship
like um there's always a person who
likes one more than out there and like
the relationships that last are the ones
where like sometimes it's witches it's
which it's like I feel like right now
like in the first maybe three years of
our relationship like Ben loved me more
than I loved him and like in the last
three years like I would love Ben more
than he really and he hates me yeah I'm
like I love him so much and he like
can't be bothered with me with
it's just not true you know it's so true
and I'm always like I know I love you
more than you love me like love me more
you say that yeah and he said what are
you talking about like no no I'm like I
know okay but like it's that's what I
get cuz like for the first three years I
feel like it was like but it's but
that's how it works
he goes to switch but Tim you think
loves who more in the lily Cole I really
like Cole likes Lily more really yeah I
hope so
meet you it was like so gorgeous and
like she deserves love she does his her
blouse she's like so well learn it and a
good role model she's so smart
like when she speaks like in interviews
that's why they always send her for
Comikaze we like that and but we know
I'm smart you know what's even weirder
about that it's like how young she is
like I could not I think she's a
youngest one on the cast it's just like
they're all like they're so young but
especially all that she's so well-spoken
and so well-read and like everything she
says she thinks a lot about before she
says it and I'm like damn when I was
your age or I am your age I just say the
dumbest [ __ ] yeah without she's like a
really good vocabulary
she took the SATs for sure okay it's
time that we move on I could talk about
Riverdale comes back on Wednesday I know
and dynasty on Friday
I can't wait for dynasty we are good at
on Fridays they got moved to Fridays in
the middle of season last year but
didn't know cuz we watched on that
flight no but it's just like a weird day
for shows to be on Blue Bloods on
Fridays Fridays it's where it's at Blue
Bloods being on Fridays makes the most
sense because just the people who watch
it
besides for us are home on Friday I'm
just trying to stand up for dynasty here
a Hollywood Reporter uh awkwafina
awkwafina honey said awkwafina's the
water so it's awkwafina
thanks Lucy Lou for quote opening the
door as host on SNL the rapper and crazy
which agents actress was the first woman
to host the NBC sketch comedy since Lucy
Liu did it 18 years ago sorry um
you have a typo Hollywood Reporter she
wasn't the first woman to host NBC
sketch comedy she was the first Asian
woman that's why it's a big deal
aquafina on Saturday became the first
Asian woman to host Saturday Night Live
in 18 years in the only second the Asian
oh my god I'm sorry this is the most
hard article to me it was a hard article
I mean it
aquafina on Saturday became the first
Asian woman to host Saturday Night Live
in 18 years and only the second Asian
woman to ever do so following Lucy Liu
stint as host in 2011 in her opening
monologue
aquafina referenced the blockbuster
romantic comedy she appeared in the
summer by noting that she is not indeed
a crazy magician just crazy
musical guest Travis Scott appeared in a
sketch about two rival crews having a
dance battle two songs
okay this is the worst written article
and I can't speak today so basically the
news is Aquafina hosted SNL which is
amazing for so many reasons one of them
is because she's the first Asian woman
to do it in 18 years and only person to
do it before her was Lucy Liu and
honestly I just love Lucy Liu and in her
monologue she thanked lucilia for making
this moment possible because she thinks
she couldn't have in here but that
people like Lucy Liu opening the door
for her which I agree
and I've two things to say about this
but I'm obviously having a hard time
getting my words out but I'll try let me
know who I'm in take over I feel like
I'm literally on drugs like you know
when you can't control yourself it's
annoying like okay take a minute
the first reason why this is amazing is
I just feel like this is the year for
asian-americans like yeah all boys I
love before crazy rich Asians and now
awkwafina being in Ocean's eleven mm-hmm
and SNL like this is just the year to be
Asian and I'm very happy for them and
I'm just I'm here for it I wanted to put
that out there
the second reason why this is so amazing
it's because awkwafina is really like an
internet personality like she got her
start on girlcode and then really dove
into digital by the way I was thinking
about this last night there's so many
people from 'girlcode who are still
relevant like I feel so everyone but
even see like that little blip in the
whatever like just like made like this
impact what that show was revolutionary
like that girl I don't even know their
names but like I just see them
everywhere like they're still here
equity now yes but now she's really um
like irrelevant in stand up right stand
up all the time Nicole Byer who I
[ __ ] love fire she was the funniest
one I can't remember oh my god
no you know you know if you saw a
picture of her she's she's black she is
she was always just making the best
jokes she's like the most eeny I think I
don't hear talk about I think it's who
I'm thinking of she's really curly hair
yes oh my god I love her so funny and
she has like really taken off in comedy
like she does so many digital series she
is always just like showing up places
where she needs to be oh my god she's so
funny
and Aquafina but she really has had like
this unbelievable career like the fact
that she was in Ocean's eleven was the
craziest thing like living with Rihanna
and sandra ball I didn't see Ocean's
eleven I saw crazier rotations and she
was my favorite character she was I just
like like - she playing Ocean's eleven
that I learned fine like yeah it was
fine and like obviously I'm like so
jealous of Aquafina so every time she
does something I like make fun of it but
like to be honest like good for her like
she's doing amazing things for like
digital people but also Asian people so
like I'm
proud of you and like thanks I guess
whatever but I just I need to find out
who or what like Asian is or her manager
because I need him or her okay figure it
out we gotta figure it out okay we can
like I feel like every time someone from
digital makes it to traditional like TV
or maybe yeah like they [ __ ] it up and
then they give people like us like a bad
name they're like oh we can't use people
from the internet like look what
happened to grace hell but you know and
it's like stop taping bad people to
transcend the internet that oh she's
just saying pick her no I'm not
aquafina I'm here I'm fine with I feel
like I really want the show oh by the
way its oceans 8 or whatever we keep the
hose is 11 I really want the pub the
lady gang show and eated you well like
even though like they're technically our
competitors whatever I want them to do
well because then people be like oh
people who have podcasts like they can
do TV like total I really want them to
succeed for my own benefit so people
like awkwafina who did it thank you
there's just so few of them now yeah I
agree because like executives choose the
worst people to take from the internet
executives are so dumb they're not in
tuned for some people who are supposed
to have like be so smart and like make
all these decisions are so dumb I can I
feel like they're always like going to
like the younger people to like help
them but like just make the younger
people the executives
it's time for you to retire right I feel
like that is happening now like but
that's really the surgery like the
people who make the biggest decisions
and are supposed to be in the most in
tune with what Millennials want like
couldn't be further from what
Millennials need and they have no idea
and they think they're so stuck in their
old ways like TV is so lame these days
oh my god they're just so not willing to
like progress I couldn't agree more also
like TV like cable like it's coming to
an end you know and just like let us
watch it on our phone it's like why
should it be so hard for me to find the
new episode of [ __ ] Blue Bloods know
right so like we had a show on Friday
night and we like wanted to watch and we
have one this Friday night like why why
is it not automatically on the CBS F the
minute after a premiere not even that it
was like our TV in the hotel had Hulu
Netflix like we should have been it
wasn't like we were on some rinky-dink
TV with fuzzy antennas like we had a
[ __ ] real TV and we could have
figured out because exactly there was
nothing to figured out it just wasn't
there and we're in tune it just it
shouldn't be that hard and that's why
things like the morning talks like we're
coming we're coming for you but really
honestly I'm like I'm proud of Aquafina
and just like thanks for like assisted
joining for themselves it's going to be
cheesier when it's my time right paving
the way paving the way speaking of
paving the way not bad that's a very
transition but it's not from
Entertainment Tonight about Carrie
Underwood Carrie Underwood displays scar
from her 2017 accident and throwback
selfie so we have the photo here take a
look basically she posted a photo on
Instagram it was a throwback of the day
she shot the music video for Love Wins
it's a selfie and it's the first time
you can really see the damage on her
face from her accident in 2017 which we
still don't really know did she did she
fell down the story is that she fell
down the stairs I feel like that's the
classic excuse she fell down no I think
she might have said she felt up the
stairs I'm like hit her face do you any
when you said when I say yeah that's
always my nightmare when I'm like
weirdly jogging up a flight of stairs
and like if I miss the stair could
literally hit my face that's what she
saying happened I just feel like that's
a go-to excuse when like you don't want
to admit what really happened there's
nothing you can say there like be like
no that didn't happen like you we can't
you have nothing to say to that and ever
since it happened her face has looked
super different and I couldn't really
put my finger on it but now I know and
it looks like a scar from like when you
have a cleft lip and you get it fixed
and then yeah like they really get rid
of it they amazingly but there is a
little scar that connects your nose to
your lip and that's really what it looks
like that's true it does I feel like if
that happened to me like because I'm so
vain I would like really like never talk
about it or show it cuz like I'm
obsessed with it well that's what she
was doing until now until she showed
that like that's what the scariest thing
yeah and like she made that whole
statement being like I'm gonna look
different and they're like when she came
out and like she definitely was ever
material doesn't like that it's like
it's like literally gorgeous either way
well either way she's fine but it must
like I would I don't think I could ever
do that like I'm always think I'm so
brave knows like I've never even posted
a picture what is that like this people
got mad that she's really said statement
that she might look different and then
she's like basically like kind of look
the same but I get it like she's gonna
feel sick to him even if it's like the
smallest thing that changes your face
like you notice it when you feel it's
like if you feel like you have to put
that statement out there just like make
yourself feel better like yeah go for it
like it to her it's probably like the
biggest deal whereas to us it's like all
right your lips look like you go just
got like some injection you got like a
little filler right exactly so like
handle it how you need to I'm like I'm
just so not here for like people telling
other people like how to have to live
their lives and how to like handle their
personal issues
like right you want to make a save it
cool make a save it but I got mad at me
for making a statement that's like when
couples break up it's like I don't even
care like don't really sustain me you
owe me nothing
I don't follow you because like I want
to I feel like I'm entitled to a reason
like I follow you because I like your
pictures and I like your movies and you
don't need to give me anything else I'm
like the world that we live in that like
demands so much from celebrities and a
reason for everything and a statement
for everything it's like really I'm a
very engaged fan and I don't find like I
need a reason for everything right but I
do need a reason for the things that I
don't get reasons for are the things I
need a reason for like I would have
liked to stateman from Beyonce and jay-z
and Solange when he beat her up like
that is something I need to know right I
don't need to know need to know by Janet
and Dewan Tatum whatever the [ __ ] her
name is are breaking up I I'd like you
guys as a couple I'm sad that you're
breaking up I don't need a reason no but
thing is like especially Ally because I
know the reason you're giving me is not
the shirt even when they do release like
the wrong wordy statement that they
probably like went over and revised 1508
something they never touched on right a
team of people exactly but I'm saying
it's like you don't have to give us all
that like the wordy [ __ ] just be
like hey we broke up like ranks just
didn't work out that's all you really
need to say like we don't need a whole
Instagram post summary notes but you
know what it's like sad like they feel
like if they don't do it like they're
not giving like they're doing the wrong
thing they feel like in informing the
public they're doing the right thing and
I just I want to put out there like as
this fan of celebrity and pop culture
like I no longer feel entitled to that
sort of information and I just think
it's like disgusting how we live in this
world I'd literally I'm with Cole
Sprouse know it makes this is what he
said but what is annoying is like I do
like to know that they broke up like I
hate like the speculation of being like
oh they haven't posted it should be so
shows like confirmation and then the end
yeah exactly that's that's what I'm
saying it's I just I know the
entitlement around being a fan of
someone is I'm not here for oh my god
people thing that they deserve so much
like you chose to like this person right
and then this the the argument is like
when this video of Hilary Duff she
posted on her Instagram like this
paparazzi literally felt she's nine
months pregnant followed her to like her
sister's home town where they much like
their kids little league game literally
all day following her I just get the
picture late how long does it take and
she confronts me she's like please leave
me alone in the comments like you asked
for it you're a celebrity like that's no
longer an acceptable answer like we're
all human beings and stop right and it's
also like she actually didn't really ask
to be a celebrity she just liked to act
and then that acting
made her celebrity was like she was like
oh I want to be famous that was a
legitimate argument back in the day
we're like People magazine was our only
source of information like we needed to
get out but like celebrities now have
the ability to post their own messages
their own photos give updates like they
no longer need paparazzi to do that they
take their we are our own paparazzi to
be so stupid
totally but if you n take a picture of
me like I'm not mad about it but that
that argument of like well you're a
celebrity you asked right it's no longer
acceptable I'm not right because that's
not reason take pictures of themselves
releases themselves and just do what
they want was right that's why I'm
saying so like [ __ ] you know so it's a
level of and make a wish I really wish
my apartment is gonna be like finished
soon I mean I know I'm getting further
and further
I ordered a couch Remzi gallery oh my
god I totally forgot that the couch it
you have is not your couch the estimated
window for delivery was late September
mid October well it's now October 8th
and every time I call they're like let's
not mid October yet no I give three more
days until it's mid-october you know
what I mean and they're like using all
the days and it's like of course it
wasn't gonna come late September it's
gonna come right you bring it Wow that's
annoying and it's technically custom so
it's like it's seven seats six of them
are mid October the seventh seat which
is custom it comes in December oh my god
it's just [ __ ] like why do couches
take so long yeah that's true like how
many people really ordering couches from
use the gallery on a daily basis that
you can't just put that with your
expensive ass but my zippers up oh and
my boob is out like it's good like
please just deliver it already every
time my phone rings I'm like oh my god
maybe it's a delivery no of course not
we are moving at just such a slow pace
today I mean I'm moving at a slow pace
tonight two stories are not really
celebrity related I just thought they
were wildly interesting but my phone is
frozen because the iPhone 10 is the
worst [ __ ] phone I've ever bought in
my life are you gonna give this problem
the excess I just I don't want to be the
first person to buy the new phone
anymore just what I did with this ten
and a grand and this is the worst phone
but I also want to get a new phone no
actually I really like this phone
there's a keeping the problems not
really mine freezes all the time and I
can't even turn it off I have to wait
for my phone to die what yes and I have
to go on my computer it's so stupid
one time it wouldn't end a FaceTime call
with Jackie little actually until my
phone died
no that matter oh well cuz you can't
shut your phone off right but that
happens to be nine shut my phone off
that you should figure that out it's so
even but this is a really interesting
stories from paychecks and I know this
affected a lot of toasters because I saw
it in the toasters group and I just
wanted to talk about it
discount airliners bankruptcy leaves
Paris Fashion Week Flyers stranded so
investment insiders at Paris Fashion
Week found themself stranded in the City
of Light is that they call it
City of Light well maybe because I kill
tower has like that's what is the city
unless love yeah I'm when they tried to
return to New York last week only to
learn that their airliner had gone out
of business budget carrier primera air
went bankrupt announcing it to
passengers without warning that all the
flights have been suspended and on the
sad day we are sad to say goodbye to
view all was in their same in the post
reported last year of the airline are
$99 flights to Europe too good to be
true obviously posted was in tune with
what's necessary in NYC fashionista told
page six I'm such a snob I'm a loyal
American Flyer executive platinum and a
million miler for life but when I book
these crazy cheap tickets popped up they
were so cheap I thought I'm just gonna
take a chance and rough it they don't
say who the blogger is but when she had
at home with her assistant we were told
the airline is bankrupt and we were
stranded at the airport Primera's
contact numbers and emails also stopped
working the fashion inside are added I
was bringing back our full collection
and was coming to miss appointments to
show it in New York but last-minute
tickets on other airlines were two
thousand dollars a pop Norwegian
Airlines saved the day by offering
flights for half price that's nice and
that is just so crazy and honestly like
hysterical sorry I just I don't get it I
thought that like when you go bankrupt
like it doesn't like just happen like
into the next hour right so but like
when things go bankrupt like they
usually like Lord and Taylor announced
our bankruptcy like a couple months ago
but they're not gonna end until December
or January same with been Dells right no
like you file for bankruptcy and you go
bankrupt but like you have some some
time yeah like I need to go to Ben
Dale's and clear them out for like home
decor like I just can't believe they
went bankrupt and then just stopped the
lying plane right that's why it's like
food and then like they're still
bankrupt they can't even pay by the way
you can't sue a bankrupt company they're
not a company anymore
that is just so weird oh my god I could
totally see that happening but how does
it honestly I mean it makes sense like
if you're shuttling people for $99 to
Paris but it's like why does it have to
be so extreme flights to Paris shouldn't
be $99 right they shouldn't be 2000 they
should be like five hundred right but
why not like yeah I didn't why didn't
the business executive who came up with
this plan of nine nine dollars not see
that that just wasn't gonna work out
it's just not feasible but I think they
wanted to make themselves like they want
to be like you don't have to fly Delta
our American a thousand dollars for
Paris like
we'll give you $99 why do they have to
be so extreme like their missus that
Martin is like structure could have
worked if they had done like a less a
lesser but more reasonable price right
why do you have to do non-agenda it all
comes down to the executives and you
know what sometimes when I see that I'm
like that's I would never I wouldn't
book it because it doesn't feel right no
it feels like where are you taking me
first right and what kind you know am I
getting on Genovia and then you know
what I mean it's like that's not what I
feel like Spirit Airlines $29 flights
I'm like I want to pay $100 like I would
like to make it there alive no I
couldn't like the price has to match the
quality item but when it doesn't like
that's what's so frustrating is like
these last-minute tickets for people who
got cancelled for $2,000 on probably
like a middle seat in the back no I mean
remember when I had to book my flight to
DC oh yeah crazy and then they cancelled
it
but nerve oh yeah so the head of nowhere
but like sever my back yeah
and we took the train which was lovely
yeah but a bunch of toasters were like
hey like I'm in Paris I live in America
I'm like I literally can't go home I
mean that's my worst nightmare like
coming home from trips either personal
or business is my greatest joy like just
right being on the way home makes my
heart fall and warm right so I'm not
having that would be devastating no
totally like every time we get the Delta
notification that's at one time or
check-in like I always think it's gonna
say it's canceled or delayed but it
doesn't just one time I know imagine if
you said hey our airline is canceled no
imagine Delta went bankrupt I just died
I mean it's Delta went bankrupt I would
be so concerned because me personally
just having been like a delta patron
loyal loyally for so many years I would
be like where the hell is my money going
do you think that it's the most
successful
airline that are generally I think
American airline and American airline is
what I'm talking about
oh not Delta no no I'm saying which
American airline not not that airline
American Airlines which is aligned in
America is the most successful
definitely not JetBlue it's probably the
smallest okay but it's the best but
because it's the smallest like they have
very limited flights like you can't fly
in to LaGuardia JetBlue they only fly
out of JFK and like Fort Lauderdale so
who do you think it is I totally think
it's Delta everyone like cool Delta yeah
but it's the most expensive I don't know
I think American really I don't know
I've never flown American
United yeah United United is the worst
if the work I think it goes in an order
of quality I mean I'm biased but I think
it goes but by the way TPG did say that
JetBlue is the best airline but I don't
think it's the most successful like I
don't they make the most money I think
it goes Delta American United JetBlue am
I forgetting in the best Oh Virgin the
Virgin went out really yeah
Virgin America nor I don't know there's
so many Airlines Southwest is the one
that it's like a movie theater you just
have to find its general admission
general admission which is so dangerous
oh my god you know anytime we board or
were anywhere like she is so nuts like
we have to we have to go to like the
gate like literally ten minutes for be
born and she doesn't sit down she stands
by like the zones and like just waits
until we get calls and then if someone
even like looks like they're trying to
cut she like you know when you talk and
say something but you want someone else
to hear it that's what she does she's
like not today and then moves up her
thing like Mozart is a thing you and
then like love to complain about my
Airport tendencies but here's the thing
human been with your low-grade medallion
status on Delta it's been zone four with
your huge ass carry on you both if you
weren't with me would be the last person
on the plane and you'd be gate checked
every [ __ ] time I'm not no I'm saying
oh you and then get to latch onto my
premium pre REM zone so you get to get
on first load your bag and then be like
one of the first off the place you are
so [ __ ] spoils and entitled I'm not
saying that I'm that's I did but I'm
saying like we could like ever like
we'll go with premium no matter what but
you just have to be the first one in the
line is my point
yeah and you know my point is shut up it
just like everyone likes to get on me
Olivia to look about my airport habits
please
I'm literally not going never missed a
flight in my life same ever furthermore
I'm a lovely passenger to sit next to
accept oh my god the weirdest thing
happened yesterday so usually I whenever
I fly Delta I will always buy a coach
ticket because nine times out of 10 I
get upgraded to first class
because of my medallion status but
in our flights yesterday our one stop I
did not which I was really upset about
but we sat next to each other so I'm
sitting on the flight division set next
to each other is a three seater I was in
the aisle and then the two other people
were a couple and this girl comes up to
me and she comes up to the guy in the
middle and she's like oh that's my seat
and he's like oh I have a seat in first
class but I want to sit next to my wife
do you want a switch so the girl was so
confused she's like you want to take my
middle seat in coach and give me your
first class scene he just wants it next
it was girlfriend was like so sweet and
she was like dumbfounded like they
couldn't communicate because they were
like she was soaking haha and she was
like okay and she like blurry I thought
she was being pranked by Ashton Kutcher
and I was like so [ __ ] jealous I'm
like oh really like if I had just
[ __ ] moved my see to the middle like
I would be in first class right now that
is so crazy but for like such a high
roller like why did that guy just get
his girlfriend the first time I'm sure
he got upgraded I'm trading bye oh oh my
god that's so crazy like things that
wouldn't ever happen to me no of course
not ever I would just get stuck in the
middle and 28th row yeah no it's never
I'm where I didn't you text and maybe
those services so that Emma Skye next to
me has first-class seat
I was said huh and then I never got an
empire so mad like I was so jealous okay
our final story is something so crazy
that I saw him Daily Mail and is really
pertinent because I have had on my
eyelid not okay not my waterline like up
here in my eyelid under my eyelashes
probably for a year I've had what looks
like a white pimple right yeah you have
and I've taken q-tips and I've tried to
pop it and it doesn't pop and then I'm
like I shouldn't [ __ ] with this it's my
eye but then I got really pissed in my
dressing room in Albany and I was like
going at it with a tweezer and some [ __ ]
came out it wasn't a pimple it was more
like a little sis right I got those and
this morning I went to look at it it was
completely gone like it's gone it's your
sound like every time I do my mascara or
my eyeliner I'm like haunted by this
little white dot and I almost like miss
it well you know what it is it's a one
time I had a wart on my thumb and they
let murder you juni Cortez if this was
like literally a million years ago my
cousin cam and it just like would never
just never go away at one time I looked
it up no I look sad pose like what do I
do some of them was like stick a needle
in it like make it bleed and have your
body
be aware that it's there and that it'll
go away I was like hmm I'll try it
then your body excites it off no so like
fight what you did you like opens it up
and your body was like oh there's a
thing there let me handle it and that's
happened sometimes just gotta wake it up
wake your body up interesting and the
wort run away no like my eyes completed
hearing today I was doing my mascara for
the first time and I was like oh let me
see how it looks ever since I slashed it
open completely gone right and I like I
miss it that's weird he should in it
used to bother me so much every time I
would look in the mirror and do like
some sort of eye makeup and like now I'm
just like a regular girl with regular
eyes but actually bothered me every time
like that I would like look at your eye
like I saw I was like little bump so now
I'm happy you saw it
yeah well cuz you made me so aware of it
you in stop talking about it how could
you see it if it was like in my eyes
because it was like right here right
yeah no I saw it well this story is
pertinent student 17 nearly dies after
popping a spot on his neck and that
triggered a deadly sepsis so if you love
to pop your pimples which I do I be
alert
hers name his name was let me try this
say this
Geraint Mullins okay he was watching
television when he noticed a pimple the
day after he popped the blemish an
abscess appeared that grew bigger and
bigger
four days later Geraint was fighting for
his life after being rushed to the
hospital he injured two surgeries to
drain the abscess as well as two blood
transfusions after spending three weeks
in the hospital he recovered and is back
home wow that is so [ __ ] crazy I
always read stories like this where it's
like a little thing that turns into
eating and like that could totally be me
I mean it could literally not only be me
it could be one of the many people whose
pimples I insist on popping right you
what he supposed to do not pop your
pimples right and I wanted to I we don't
have a picture of what it was but I
don't like it no I want to see what it
was before what did it look like was it
a white head was it a black head was it
a blemish like what was it right or like
did it look like not right right like
sometimes you know that you can't pop
something like right but I did right
okay but if no it wouldn't have happened
already didn't happen right away the
next day okay let's open oh I did this
on Friday
yeah we're chilling we're chilling but
like they say that you're really not
supposed to pop your pimples because on
the outside you see like puss come out
and it's good but on the inside it could
have popped backwards and like right and
delivered bacteria into your body right
you're really just supposed to let it
heal itself but like but I feel like
those white headed pimple doesn't just
go away
have to pop it you gotta like that no I
mean that's like the final stage before
it goes away oh it's like it's red no it
starts with like a little pain you don't
see you come in you feel a pimple under
the surface then over time it comes to
the surface it gets a little red it
becomes a like a bump then the final
stage is it's white and you're supposed
to let it go well obviously it happens
so enticing yeah I mean I'm not even
really enticed by whiteheads like I am
la black head perplexed by black heads I
like first of all dr. pimple popper her
pages taken a turn we're like I really
can't look at it anymore
me too and by the way every single video
is that Instagram warning that says
sensitive content because these big
cysts in people's skulls I don't want I
want like an old man's nose with like
little blackheads like she used to have
this patient who was a firefighter for
years and he's like in his 80s now and
his nose is like so filled with bacteria
because of like the smoke that like
literally he has the deepest blackheads
like that's what I want to say I don't
need to see literally blood sweat it do
you remember when we were younger we
before dr. thimble Hopper we used to
watch like painful videos on YouTube
like it was like a thing gross
she was really onto something but she's
really disgusting me now but she should
have this guy in his patients see what
happen she um she got a show right TLC
what I think what is it just like
popping so she had a special like they I
think they just tested like she did like
a one-hour thing and a lot of people
liked it so now I don't know if it's
like a weekly show but she does like
frequent specials where she has like
people come in with like a rare diseases
it's like botched almost like they come
in they're like oh I'm here sittuation
and she says he's what she can do i
watch um wait what I have totally for
out I was gonna say Oh dr. grandma
popper is one of those accounts that
like I refused to follow but check up on
all the time right before bed it's a
great opportunity just to like make
yourself not so great it's one of those
great accounts like look for like while
you're watching TV no it's a great
account to watch when you're trying to
dye it because you'll never want to go I
can't like I literally can't watch the
big ones like I like I just can't like I
skip like again but I'd you like to
check up she should make a blackhead
specific like her like I know a hashtag
yeah that way like you can just like
take out all the other ones Sandra Lee
she really is come so far good for her I
hope she's like really successful like
well she was successful before cuz she's
a dermatologist like I
just held living in Florida that's sure
now this is probably like she got to add
a wing to her mansion yeah uh must be
nice
must I could use a mansion right now I
can use a lot of things right now most
importantly like a massage and a bed and
food
we got a massage in the Atlanta Airport
at the Express aw I just want to say
that place is [ __ ] expensive we got a
20 minute massage it was each $50 still
worth it yeah cuz we woke it up at 4:00
a.m. for our flight at 6:00 a.m. out of
Albany you know I'm sorry we woke up at
3:30 yeah it makes a difference yeah I
went to bed at like 1:00 okay
I've never broken up at 3:30 no me
neither it lately in my life like I was
being kidnapped I know because I was
kidnapping myself we woke up at 3:30 and
by the way we were we never heard that
gotta be so early to the airport it was
like a small janky Airport like they had
nothing and everything was closed
there's no skies nothing that's what we
were talking about that I really feel
like is in foreign point I want to make
on this show the fact that there are
like parts of the airport that close at
certain hours is really bizarre because
the last flight in most airports is
midnight and then the first flight of 6
a.m. so there's like 6 hours we're like
no one's supposed to do anything like at
the restaurants close and it's just like
but it's not fair to people who wake up
at 3:30 that have it then need this
stuff more than the person who's just
singing it dude
yeah I don't need [ __ ] Hudson news no
I mean that for the morning totally and
like it was just the craziest thing ever
cuz like when we landed and we were in
Atlanta and we had the layover like it
was 8:00 a.m. people still hadn't had
woken up yet and we like had this whole
journey and we still have another ways
to go right and like me and Judy Cortes
over here we're just like so hungry
there were so many dining options in
Atlanta no yeah well the sky for the I
like dream about the sky club's more
watery eggs cuz like they're just so
great especially like when you're so
hungry we like just never really eat on
tour because like we just can't figure
it out kind of yeah
and then I can't believe that you are
engaged to Meghan Trainor I'm not I'm
not following Junie I'm just going along
with this joke what visit Spy Kids
he always has band-aids on his finger oh
my god he's an agent mention juni Cortez
yes I don't know his real name he is not
engaged to Meghan Trainor right yes and
he like
it's like her house and Alexa Vega and
kena Vega Pennebaker and they are on
homework now looking movies together
well Judy Cortez I don't know his real
name is engaged Meghan Trainor oh my god
and notes also just something that I'll
never get over is that landry and
kirsten dunst are married and like I
feel gen and are perfect for each other
yeah they kind of look alike they look
alike their child is gonna look just
like them yeah they both aged somewhat
gracefully and they're both just like
from epic teenage moments right that's
right and I went Slade man in the
industry oh they're both on a show
called Fargo oh they are I think she is
I think kids do wait anyway what was I
talking about and he was in Breaking Bad
he had such a weird career he has had
such a weird career like he definitely
is a good amount of money and like is
well-known in the industry but like he
can go to 7-eleven and get a soda and
like no one cares you know what's so
weird is that um I was watching blood
line with Kyle Chandler and he was in it
and it must be so weird like having that
choker but what I was talking about Oh
back to 3:30 a.m. is that it's just so
crazy because by the time that we
actually got to Alabama we were in the
hotel there was a one hour time
difference what you think doesn't really
make a difference but it does we got we
had had the longest day ever and it was
10:30 10:30 in the morning we've been
all over this country we had been all
over this country we had done so many
things had like one meal and he's just
10 13 like people still weren't even
awake yet it's so great that day made me
realize that there are 24 hours in a day
and that's a long day but I don't know
that cuz I usually wake up at 11:00 like
go to sleep later and like it's just I
didn't realize but like you can get a
lot of [ __ ] done how how many hours a
day do you think you're awake I wake up
at 8:00 and go to bed at midnight well
honestly ever since I'm like I've gone
through this life changes like it being
a working woman and a full-time student
my hours have completely changed like I
used to like go to sleep it like - and
like wake up at 2:00 and I'd have my
first class at 3:00 and like to stroll
in like whatever now I like I'm striking
and jobs shucking jiving sleeping by
midnight and like today I feel like
we're jet-lagged because today we had we
wake up at like 9:00 right and I woke up
at 7:00 and I was like wow I've been
asleep for too long it's like I'm just
not used to being asleep yeah for that
long and I was like wow two more hours
that's great and then that happened the
night two nights ago when we were waking
up for our flight to come home we went
to be like 1:30 it had to make about
like 837
it's unheard of and we local eleven we
were like wow we can continue to sleep
that's crazy
I really feel like this conversation
about our travels is so uninteresting to
other B that's true but for us he's just
so harrowing yeah I think I kind of I
personally can't believe we did it
I can't believe I'm alive no no like I
just I just would never take us as girls
who could wake up at 3:30 no and I'm
like now I'm so grateful for the next
three weeks that I have because like
they're so great like yeah this week
strolling into Atlanta Friday morning
one show at a huge dinner I'm so excited
I think it's like 1,100 seats and I'm
still this is my biggest venue yet and
like the [ __ ] Atlanta toasters like
showed the [ __ ] up like I think we're at
1100 I believe like 800 of them are sold
which like for anyone is great well they
still have a week left and I know that
lemon toasters are gonna sell it out for
me cuz like they're just the best so
much so happy about that and then I only
have to do one show so I can put really
all my energy into this one she'll like
what I have to do - I really need to
conserve my energy but for this I'm just
like leaving it all to me one show is
truly personally changed my life and
then next week we're in Cleveland for
one show mm-hmm in and out easy one hour
two hour flight I don't even know we got
to that Boston to show so that's gonna
be treacherous but yeah that's gonna be
crazy and I just feel like now and like
really getting into a group of like how
I want to do my shows yes like we were
doing whatever we like whatever they
like booked [ __ ] does you we did but
now we just understand we're in charge I
care what time - needed like poor shows
in two days six shows in Chicago like
geez and you know it's like that's not
fair the people buying the tickets cuz
like I'm not gonna be as good if I drink
six shows
no oh my god I think in Chicago I was
five or six yeah you talked about the
slide that I'd like anyone who was at
the sixth show in Chicago and you'll
know if you are if you were at the sixth
one if you ever want to come to another
show like I will comp you ticket cuz
that was the worst shot we ever did I'm
man enough to admit it no not every show
can be a banger that every joke can be a
banger but honestly all I yet to be on
see a show that was bad
ya know I've sometimes I know that I can
do better and like that upsets me no but
like even like your worst show it's
still really good and really solid and
people probably thought it was
absolutely hilarious well I would say
that my first show in Buffalo was
fantastic yes but I fit of the week and
your best show is by far Alabama
I think so too just because the crowd
was really with you there yeah except I
actually think about flow was maybe a
little bit better or someone proposed I
think right but like I was talk about
you yeah the
I think here notice I was better in
Huntsville the Buffalo crowd was like
more engaged like the Huntsville crowd
was turnt and like they were a little
loud and like not listening to me at
some points which is annoying but I
think my eye performs better Jamie yeah
I'm just excited like I'm just I feel
like I'm getting so much better in every
show no and now it's our to Co making at
some of the shows they have the ability
to tape but for me which is so helpful
that I can like watch myself back and
it's so funny because I never watch the
toast ever because like I know that I'm
good at it and I don't want to hear my
own voice but for the Comique stuff like
I really do need to watch it like my
game tape because I need to know what I
could be doing better
right um like I realized when I watched
one I tapes from DC which was an amazing
show uh I say too many times in the
beginning like thank you guys for coming
I think I'm just like nervous in the
beginning and I'm I think you need to
say it once totally yeah but that's like
my go-to when I'm nervous
yeah but like just I guess I didn't
watch Kardashians or Blue Bloods which
I'll watch today because I have a full a
full day yeah watch presentation have it
at me and I hear that everyone's not
really loving Kim but she can't do
anything wrong in my eyes so yeah no I
heard I won't agree with you no matter
what I heard she called to Kourtney or
grandma she has whatever so thank you
guys so much for tuning into the morning
toast I'm back tomorrow with someone we
have gotten so many requests for but he
is so [ __ ] busy that he can never
Cohoes and I litter I need you triple
confirm with him today I already double
confirmed but he's my make sure it's
coming tomorrow joey camasta he's the
co-host of this Mickey podcast it's it's
happening it's all happening um he is
Snooki's hair makeup artist he is an
influencer he's so funny and he is so in
tune with what's necessary yeah
if the toast a lot of the toasters know
him and requested him but if you don't
know him like you will love him so I'm
really excited for that we have no
guests and then Jackie is back on
Wednesday which will be really exciting
so everyone make sure to follow the
morning show some Facebook and YouTube
because we live stream every day Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
so like us on Facebook at the morning
toast like uh some YouTube subscribe to
us on YouTube and then we're also
available as podcasts anywhere you can
hear podcasts so make sure to subscribe
and Apple Spotify I'll play says thank
you guys so much for listening have an
amazing day
[Music]
you